voilà une vidéo que je voulais faire
depuis un petit moment faire une faq ça
fait longtemps qu'on n'en a pas fait à
se poser des questions répondre à
discuter ensemble et échanger
directement il a effectué c'est
intéressant pour ça alors c'est vrai
qu'on le fait parfois surtout leach
parfois sur youtube mais là c'est
l'occasion devront se fait une petite
faq petit jeu c'est pas la longueur il
ya des questions je vais répondre à vos
questions et on commence tout de suite
avec la question de christophe mais
avant générique
[Musique]
c'est parti alors christophe salue
monsieur gruger les couverts tâche et il
ya très peu de temps s'il veut de bons
concédant sept jeunes de nouvelles
technologies hockey penses-tu faire le
test du téléphone cros cole actions et 5
non c'est pas prévu monsieur gros petite
question quel équipement utilises tu
dans ta vie smartphone monde connecté
ordinateur portable alors j'utilise un
mac macbook pro j'ai un iphone 13 promax
et là j'ai une apple loi je suis très
apple j'aime toutes les marques
attention je n'ai pas du tout de parti
pris mais je te dise pourquoi lorsque
les montages je les faisais du mois
qu'il fait en ce moment mais je les
faisais sur mac et sur final cut pro
final cut pro c'est mad max et apple ça
communique très bien avec son iphone
c'est la raison pour laquelle je fais et
en plus de ça cette petite bête elle
marche très très bien pour aller faire
des vidéos rapide pour faire du contenu
tik tok et compagnie donc c'est
vachement bien voilà on salue monsieur
re je me demandais quelle est
l'évolution innovations techniques
majeures que tu attends impatiemment
cake majeur j'attends impatiemment ça
dépend quel à quelle échéance tu vois si
c'est sur l'échéance de cette année je
pense que j'ai hâte de voir tous les
smartphones nokia qui vont sortir tous
les formats qu'est ce qui va arriver si
on regarde un peu plus loin dans le
temps je pense que ça pourrait tout ce
qui va arriver en termes d'horaires et
buzz gens parlent beaucoup c'est à dire
le fait de pouvoir avoir des objets
connectés intégré au travers d'une
montre mais pourquoi pas au travers de
vêtements d'antan une chose ça pourrait
arriver beaucoup plus tard le futur un
peu plus lointain mais ça pourrait
m'intéresser pense qu'apple
s'intéressera un jour aux smartphones
payants comme samsung ou technologie ne
sera jamais abouti est intéressante à
exploiter que navy travaillent déjà
dessus ils ont déjà des proto je pense
qu'il est beaucoup trop tôt pour apple
aujourd'hui et sortir un smartphone qui
se plie mais ça arrivera c'est logique
c'est dans la suite de l'histoire donc
oui mais quand le marché serait mûr
l'espace est bonne facture en bonne
santé je vais très bien je t'en remercie
latino ma question est la suivante ans
tu pouvoir parler tester les produits du
cis genre en particulier des nouveaux pc
portables bonne continuation tué top
merci beaucoup oui oui c'est prévu je
vais tester un pc d'asus prochainement
c'est prévu est connecté tu verras ça
bientôt bien évidemment quels sont tes
projets futurs pour ta chaîne continue
comme ça j'adore ton contenu merci
beaucoup dylan jeudi et que tout de
suite ce qui est le plus important pour
moi c'est de faire bien ce que j'ai
commencé à faire et c'est souvent le
problème que j'ai c'est que je commence
plein de trucs et puis des fois je suis
débordée par le temps donc là déjà j'ai
délégué mais montage c'est plus moi qui
les fais ça me permet d'avoir beaucoup
plus de temps qu'on pouvoir relancer mon
podcast qui ressorti pour pouvoir
prendre du temps à travailler différents
contenus à faire plus de vidéos là j'ai
remonté le rythme de vidéos sur youtube
à développer tik tok a développé twitch
à développer instagram on va il ya plein
de choses à faire là et une fac tout ça
roulera je dirais sur un rythme un petit
peu constant on va pouvoir faire
d'autres choses parce que j'ai plein de
projets en tête tu pense qu'il y aura
d'autres formes facteurs bientôt alors
j'imagine que tu me parles de
smartphones je pense que oui je pense
que le pliable si tu veux ça permet de
nous montrer que l'on peut commencer à
jouer avec les objets à à moduler les
tailles donc on va pouvoir faire
beaucoup plus de choses et quand je
reviens à l'idée du r est bel et bien
moi je pense que deux objets
technologiques ont vocation à être
intégré à nous si on veut des implants
bon on n'est pas du tout je sais pas si
on y arrive en un jour mais en tout cas
été mieux intégrer plutôt qu'avoir un
truc qu'on tient la main qu'on risque de
faire tomber de glisser que quand on le
tient on a les mains prises et c'est pas
hyper évident donc je pense
qu'effectivement il y aura d'autres
formes factor mais pour qu'il soit
pertinent et intéressant et encore
falloir attendre quelques années moi
tout simplement thomas ça a était quoi
ton innovation préféré en 2021 je dirais
que ce qui m'a surpris le plus c'est du
côté de au pot celle au pot et kz2 1021
vous savez c'est leur smartphone qui
sont roule je trouve ça très très cool
et très surprenant pour le coup j'ai
beaucoup aimé combien tu déboursés en
objet high-tech inutile nous avait pas
d'autre idée alors ça me laissait aucune
question est inutile pour tout dire je
suis auvergnat je ne dépense jamais
d'argent c'est pas vrai mais pour le
coup je n'achète pas les objets high
tech s'est démarqué mais sans voix je
déteste mais je les achète pourquoi que
j'ai les projets de vidéos je pense que
je vais en acheter quelques uns parce
que je les recevrai pas seul on verra ça
plus tard marc j'aimerais savoir où
acheter le honor magic3 pro +
introuvable en europe un vendeur à me
conseiller et coup je me suis pas du
tout poser sur la question je t'invite à
aller voir des vendeurs comme gears
baisse qui peuvent avoir des produits
comme ça ça peut potentiellement être
intéressant mais je te cache pas que
mise à part eux équivalent comme ça je
vois pas trop combien d'appareils comme
des smartphones pc enceinte montre à
tuant tout grâce à des vidéos là je dois
être à une cinquantaine de smartphones
je pense
20 montre quelques petites enceintes pc
y en avoir cinq six j'en ai quelques-uns
alors je les conserve pas pour en faire
une collection mais pour pouvoir
comparer voir l'évolution c'est ça qui
est intéressant surtout et je trouve
pertinent savez monsieur grosse gt pro
web plus je vais passer un samsung s 22
ultra attention n'est pas encore annoncé
que penses tu de l'évolution de la
marque one plus depuis le système en
termes de photographie surtout avec le
partenariat seul blade design aussi
alors je pense que one plus il se
retrouve confronté aujourd'hui une
saturation du marché donc c'est
compliqué pour eux de sortir très peu de
modèles on l'a vu ils ont élargi la
gamme mais bon c'est pas suffisamment
évident je pense qu'avec un seul blade
ils ont vraiment un très gros coup à
jouer l'année dernière on a vu un truc
vachement bien du côté de la série 9 ils
ont annoncé de très très belles choses
cette année j'ai hâte de les tester et
de voir parce qu'en photo salaire quand
même bien bien lourd maintenant je pense
que c'est une marque qui est aussi en
difficulté qui se rapproche de au pot
pour venir mutualiser les coûts font
partie du même groupe en fait comme
toutes boîtes aujourd'hui dans des
domaines très concurrentiel essayer de
tirer leur épingle du jeu des
différentes faire de nouvelles
propositions pour exister et puis on qui
sait ce qui pour arriver du côté de chez
swann plus en tout cas sont toujours là
avec de belles innovations et beau
partenariat donc ça c'est chouette que
pour ceux du chargeur magsafe spiegel je
l' ai pas testé pour tout dire mais
c'est une marque sérieuse propose de
beaux produits donc bon il n'y a pas de
raison que ça se passe mal bonjour
monsieur greu qu'elle sera selon toi la
grande tendance thème de cette année
house assez compliquée j'en sais rien la
grande tendance tech je pense que déjà
il va y avoir une démocratisation du
pliable avec de plus en plus d'acteurs
donc on va retrouver des smartphones
pliable un peu tous les côtés à tous les
formats donc ça va être un truc qui va
être intéressant de 2022 va être l'année
de démocratisation attention ça touchera
pas tout de suite tout le grand public
mais il ya un paquet fait 2023 davantage
sur le plus grand public pourquoi parce
que voir que les prix baissent et plus
il y aura de concurrence là dessus plus
les gens vont acheter plus les prix
baisseront donc ça serait intéressant
mais peut-être plus tôt 2023 dans la
grande tendance tech de cette année j'ai
pas vu de courant ou on dit ouah tiens
il ya un truc et hop là il faut le
prendre je pense qu'on est plus dans des
périodes de belles évolutions plutôt que
de grandes tendances texte pas si vous
êtes d'accord d'ailleurs marqué les mois
en commentaire corentin et monsieur vos
j'espère que ça fait très bien continuer
ce que tu fais je suis pas mal de temps
c'est toujours un point de regarder des
vidéos mercy corps en tapant stuc apple
va finir par sortir du podium des
meilleurs constructeurs de smartphones
car ils font des smartphones de plus en
plus cher et des innovations également
retard sur les smartphones android
aujourd'hui notamment le stockage
interne l'encoche et à place de la
caméra alors je suis pas forcément
d'accord avec toi corentin je ne pense
pas que apple est en retard ou propose
des innovations égal je pense qu'à des
choses qu'on ne voit ah je pense que la
force d'apple c'est effectivement de
maîtriser tout ce soit le software ou la
construction et on l'a vu d'ailleurs y'a
pas longtemps avec les macbook et avec
les puces m 1 donc non je pense qu'ils
sont pas du tout en retard je pense
qu'au contraire ils sont bien dans leur
temps ils maîtrisent très bien le
calendrier ils ont été un peu en retard
certain design on voit que l'encoche
elle commence un peu à souffrir mais je
vous en ai parlé dans ma vidéo sur les
rumeurs l'iphone 14 il semblerait que
sept ans que je disparaisse au profit
d'une bulle et d'un poinçon on verra
bien évidemment dans la deuxième partie
de l'année si c'est avéré mais je pense
pas vraiment pas qu'ils soient à la
bourre les écrans sont toujours
magnifiques l'audio est très bon très
bien spécialisés sur les mac ça marche
vachement bien être une performance de
dengue sur les mac il ya une super
solutions logicielles et une
interconnectivité entre tous les
produits qui est juste magique et
magnifique non pour moi ils sont très
très bon apple maintenant sentir du
podium pour les smartphones je suis
d'accord avec toi pourquoi non pas parce
que en valeur ils sont pas bons en
valeur ils sont très très très bon mais
en volume ils seront un peu moins bons
parce qu'ils ont moins de produits au
catalogue que ce que peuvent avoir des
concurrents comme des symptômes ou des
chiots mais s'adresse pas à tout le
monde en fait ça reste très premium même
si l'iphone est ce reste un smartphone
plus milieu de gamme donc un peu plus
pour tout le monde c'est plutôt là
dessus en fait sur le volume mais en
termes de business de chiffre d'affaires
et de valeurs apple il reste quand même
ou vachement très clairement donc je
pense que j aime ce que tu fais merci et
j'aime ton message ib continue comme ça
quel est selon toi le meilleur pc que tu
as testé et quel est celui que tu
conseilles angers s'était plaint de pc
très très cool beaucoup d'efficacité du
côté de chez huawei alors je sais que
c'est en partenariat avec eux mais pour
autant j'aime bien leur machine j'étais
des jolies choses du côté de chez asus
il essaye vraiment des choses marrantes
asus avec des ordinateurs un peu hybride
assez rigolo le fait d'arriver également
avec un ordinateur pliable je trouve ça
assez malin il ya très très belle
innovation chez asus j'ai pas un grand
testeurs pc1 jeantaise parce que je
trouve ça cool mais il ya des chaînes
qui sont plus spécialisés dans le pc que
moi le meilleur que j'ai testé je pense
que chez asus j'ai vu des trucs est un
peu plus what the fuck et c'est vraiment
ce que je vais mais c'est l'innovation
jeudi l'asus j'ai testé la monde
connecté garmin phoenix est c'est pas
prévu carmelo comment ça va les gars je
vais bien et toi comment ça va grille
aura t'il vraiment un stylo intégré dans
le f-22 leur sapin ce sera un style ça
sera le s pen je pense que oui parce que
ils nous ont montré en publiant fait qu
un teasing où on voit des ombres de
smartphones on croit deviner un s-21
ultra on croit deviner un galaxy ne
devint ultra on les voit tourbillonner
pour faire par un seul et même
smartphone un seul et même smartphone
bravo l'articulation monsieur vote donc
ça veut dire que oui je pense
effectivement
la vocation du modèle ultra dans la
gamme s est bien c'est d'arriver en
équivalent de gamme note c'est à dire
avec un stylet qu'on peut venir intégrer
rangé directement et quel smartphone tu
prendrais en 2022 or samsung et iphone
il ya plein de jolies choses si je
devais prendre un en dehors d'apple et
de samsung je pense que j'essaierai des
smartphones chez omis parce que tu as
des super rapport qualité prix parce que
tu as de belles finitions parce que tu
as très jolie innovation je pense que
j'ai fait un truc par la slim 77' lui
monsieur greu meilleur testeur mobiles
et tablettes merci beaucoup que penses
tu de l'évolution de l'os android le 12
vient à peine d'être déployée qu'on
parle du trésor fait tous les ans si tu
veux ils sortent une évolution est mise
à jour de nouvelles fonctionnalités moi
j'aime bien android j'aime bien ce
qu'ils proposent ils se renouvellent
matériel you on a vu l'année dernière
avec toute cette question de
personnalisation de customisation parce
que le smartphone est plus juste un
objet de teck et qui rend service à un
objet lifestyle c'est là dessus qu'ils
veulent aller on peut le customiser on
peut la sortir à ses vêtements c'est un
objet de mode et je trouve que le
travail qu'ils ont fait avec le 12 là
dessus avait vraiment insensée puis on
verra ce qui va arriver sur le 13 on va
suivre ça ps sûrement find x3 pro ça bug
depuis que j'ai fait le 12 alors moi ce
que je sais c'est de faire une
sauvegarde et puis de reboot et de
réinstaller et de recommencer pour voir
parce que c'est le fan x3 pro est quand
même extrêmement récent et c'est pas
normal que tu puisses avoir des bugs
avec android ou de rien ce talent tous
mes sauvegardes avant elle salue
monsieur grehan 22 tu attendais quoi
comme innovation nouvelles technologies
sur les smartphones étaient quand même
le général comme disait tout à l'heure
en fait un des innovations voir ce qui
va arriver du côté du pliable pas de
grosses techno qui disent que de me
surprendre je peux me tromper on vers
des améliorations au niveau de la caméra
au niveau des écrans des taux de
rafraîchissement va réapprendre à monter
plus haut niveau taux de
rafraîchissement enfin bref mais je
m'attends pas je ne sens pas tu vois là
la grosse ovation tout du moins ça sans
innovation oulala ça va arriver je le
non jeu on verra c'est quoi ton
smartphone coup de coeur quels sont tes
projets pour les prochains mois sur la
chaleur smartphone coup de coeur je
pense que j'ai bien aimé ce que j'ai vu
chez opodo deux jours avec le fine n le
format un peu plus petit en pliable
c'est à dire qu'on a comme dans l'idée
d'un samsung galaxy z folle de trois on
vient l'ouvrir comme un livre sauf que
le format un peu plus petit c'est plus
compact on sent pas trop la pliure ça
j'ai bien aimé donc j'aimerais que ça
arrive même si pour l'instant ce n'est
pas prévu en france mais quels sont tes
projets pour les prochains mois sur la
chaîne mc au musée de thaler c'est tout
développer stabiliser voilà la base
composent la base et on n'avance pas
c'est déjà bien et salle du petit faire
des vidéos sur la technologie dans le
domaine de la santé
ah ouais ça serait vachement cool alors
en fait là j'ai fait une vidéo qui est
publié c'est le monde en 2030 au travers
du prisme de la technologie et notamment
je parle de dents de la santé connecter
et de la biotech donc oui on pourrait en
parler je vous un sujet extrêmement
passionnant alors voilà pour toutes les
questions que j'ai eu six ans j'en ai
d'autres là qui sont arrivées de l'autre
côté sur instagram on va se les regarder
ensemble que penses tu de la marque
xiaomi la communauté j'aime beaucoup
très très jolie marque avec plein de
produits puis la communauté des mille
fans et très cool tu penses que l'on
aura un iphone et ce deux années un
iphone et ce trois je pense davantage ma
question se base sur le web médecin
quand est ce qu'il sera présentée cette
année j'ai aucune info là-dessus pour
l'instant des partenariats en
préparation des partenariats bien
évidemment préparation parce que comme
je suis indépendant et je suis en effet
pas le terme influenceurs mais en tout
cas je suis créateur de contenu et
notamment tout de suite sur youtube ce
qui me fait vivre à ses alors la
publicité met notamment les partenariats
donc il faut des partenariats donc voilà
oui il y aura des partenariats tu
m'offres un tel bien essayé meilleur
écouteurs sans fil à moins de 200 euros
groix ou alors ça dépend si tu veux des
écouteurs sans fil optimisé pour eyeos
optimisé pour android si c'est pour ios
va regarder du côté des airs pop bien
évidemment je crois qu'il ya pas grand
chose à raconter de l'autre côté sur
android et je pense que tu peux aller
voir du côté des samsung galaxy s2 je ne
me rappelle plus du tarif mais très très
bon j'ai des petits car l'autre côté
merci twitch et le podcast en 2022 en
tout cas continue sur wii alors oui
alors podcast ses revenus ça c'est fait
c'est acté on peut y aller on peut
l'écouter twitch antec qui était
toujours là sur twitter je te remercie
en fait là tout de suite twitch je veux
le faire c'est clair clair clair j'adore
ça il faut juste que j'arrive à pouvoir
sûr d'être l'art peut-être un format
comme je faisais le midi peut-être un
format du soir j'adore la quotidienne je
sais pas il faut que j'arrive à trouver
mais on reparte c'est pour ça l'idée ce
soit disait c'est de lire pérenniser les
choses d asseoir les poser et ensuite
pouvoir y aller pas combien d'objets
connectés un pack et tu vas essayer le
nouveau processeur snapdragon huit gènes
one peut-être plus d'infos je n'ai pas
testé j'ai fait un benchmark lorsqu'on
était à hawaï et ou sur le benchmark
était dingue mais je n'ai pas testé pour
tout dire est-ce que tu prévois de
nouveaux formats et de concept de vidéo
à venir en lien ou pas avec la tête j'ai
toujours des idées on va voir j'ai
vachement les quatre petites vidéos
comme ça des fois de tutos d'astuces de
partager des secrets sur ça cool en plus
des tests ont plus de l'actu plus des
news d'ailleurs je sais pas si ça vous
paie d'ailleurs dit le mans aux
commentaires est ce que vous allez
tester la galaxie watch 4
je ne pense pas nolan quand est-ce que
tu reviens clermont ferrand j'y suis
tout de suite quand est ce qu'on aura la
sortie du est 22e moitié vrille que
penses tu du fpv et des drôles en
général l appareil d des drones je pense
parce que drôle dans les trucs drôles
s'ils utilisent quoi comme caméra
smartphone ordi et compagnie là je filme
avec un sony alpha nas et s3 smartphone
jeudi c'est un iphone et puis mac qu'est
ce que tu penses dur et demi note 11
beaucoup de bien pour l'instant aucun ps
tu es génial je préfère toujours à toi
quand je dois acheter de l'high-tech
merci beaucoup c'est un amour que penses
tu du progrès l'innovation technologique
en règle générale le progress ça va dans
le sens de l'histoire donc ça me plaît
toujours l'innovation technologique ça
me plaît il faut qu'ils passent en
technologie qui ait un sens il faut
qu'elles apportent des solutions
qu'elles résolvent des problèmes et
c'est ça que je trouve intéressant
plutôt et flip z fold ou des écrans
enroulable ton aviva quel va être le
format le plus populaire est ce que tu
as vu le proto de tcl où tu as un format
de folles qui s'enroulent ça ça me
paraît pas mal tu as les deux essais par
modulaire à quand une vidéo sur le wan
+10 prod et qui sera disponible bien
évidemment pourquoi elle et elle passe
pas en ddr4 ah ça c'est une question
quelle est la marque qui sera au
tournant selon toi cette année chez au
mi6 arrive leader ça serait fat le pixel
6 en un mot j'ai droit à trois micros
quatre mots pour la faute aux trop dire
penses-tu recruter des stagiaires qui
aimeraient apprendre son métier
j'aimerais mais le problème c'est la
capacité de former correctement et comme
je suis toujours à droite à gauche c'est
compliqué est ce que tu es déjà tombés
sur une marque de smartphones quasi
inconnu je suis déjà testé sur des
marques de smartphones assez peu connu
en france un peu plus ailleurs oui il y
en a il y en a quelques-uns quelques-uns
comment ça va ça va très bien et toi
johan peux-tu m'offrir un smartphone
bien essayé bonjour monsieur heureux que
penses tu du honor 50 pro savez vous
quand il sortira en france je n'ai
aucune info web à elle je n'ai pas testé
le salon était bien le proprement un peu
plus bien mais sinon je sais pas tu
qu'on sait quoi comme picot
vidéoprojecteur j'avais fait le picopix
de phyllis j'étais pas mal on va
reparler vidéo proches bientôt donc
reste connecté sur youtube il ya mon
pote fred qui met lots monsieur bretons
nous en dire plus sur ton statut et la
partie un peu plus business coûts de
fret ça pourra faire l'objet d'une autre
d'une vidéo je pense entière peut-être
parlé un petit peu de business à voir
comment ça se passe derrière mais je
suis en une heure elle pour tout savoir
comme toute personne qui crée du contenu
sur les réseaux sociaux je dois
forcément vivre comme je disais tout à
l'heure de partenariats avec les marques
donc mais je pense qu'on en reparlera
parce que ça sera un sujet intéressant à
développer et là en 15 secondes c'est un
petit peu compliqué mais on en reparle
et merci fred pour ta question bonjour
monsieur creux pensez vous que le
prochain s 22 ultra de samsung sera
innovante mise à jour car il sera
innocent je pense sur l'innovation à
quel âge as-tu 42 avant qu vite tu
cherchais un monteur vidéo je crois que
tu aurais fait mes vidéos oui oui
laurent absolument est en fait je
passais par une boîte de prod par une
boîte de prod qui m'est fait parce
qu'elle elle m'assure d'avoir toujours
un monteur de dispo tout temps toute
l'année donc c'est très con fort pour
moi quatre ans tue deux modèles d'iphone
des infos sur la table et suite d'ultra
aucune que devient htc ils font des
casques je sais qu'il ya un espace on
pouvait aller les voir au csa vegas donc
ils font des casques en plus de
smartphones donc c'est pour ça je
regrette un petit peu moins mais il ya
de la réalité virtuelle a bien
évidemment chez htc mac os windows les
deux c'est une question de logiciels
c'est une question d'habitude mais les
deux bien évidemment j'ai actuellement
au webmail 20 x 5 g connaître es tu un
smartphone pouvant lui succéder alors si
tu veux rester chez huawei est à plein
de jolies solution tu as plein de bons
produits dans la mesure où tu vas leur
harmonie os et la galerie du 3 de très
jolies choses sinon alors la grosse
force du mail 20 x tu avais
effectivement toute la partie photo et
performance c'est des machines qui
cartonne à fond chihuahua tu trouveras
l'équivalent bien évidemment mais si tu
veux rester avec des services google
samsung galaxy s 21 entre très très cool
assez cher mais très très cool mais les
prix ont baissé et vont continuer à
baisser très belle machine bonjour à toi
est-ce que tu saurais si le espagne pour
être compatible avec le s20 ultra es21
ultra le s20 ultra je ne crois pas parce
qu'il ya une gamme note 20 mai le s-21
ultra oui le téléphone qui t'a le plus
marqué et continu me sentais super merci
le téléphone qui m'a le plus marqué je
crois que c'est l'innovation sur les
pliable un très clairement j'ai dit
alors un qui m'a beaucoup plu qui vient
tout de suite à la tête c'est le au pot
x 2021 que penses tu du wawel j'en ai
déjà parlé j'aime beaucoup la marque
huawei il propose d'éditer super produit
qu'un super hardware qui continue à
avancer pour arriver au nid dû justement
du software sur smartphone donc il ya
toute la partie smartphones qui est un
peu plus compliqué pour eux parce qu'il
faut développer tous ces partenariats
avec des développeurs pour avoir une
solution complète équivalente à ce qu'on
trouve du côté des services google donc
du côté de votre android mais pour
autant ça marche moins bien et si vous
regardez tout ce qu'ils font dans le
reste au niveau des pc ça marche du feu
de dieu quel smartphone peut y apprendre
pour rentrer dans l'univers du pillage
rentrer dans l'univers galaxy z flip 3
directement quel smartphone construire
est tu pour entrer dans l'univers dopo
oppose j'entrerai par le obr sur le
finepix 3 pro tu vois clairement ça ça
me botterait sinon le réno 6 quel
opérateur mobile serait le plus fiable
aujourd'hui en france j'ai pas de data
mais j'ai un partenariat avec bouygues
telecom donc quand est ce qu arrivera
android 12 dont coût annuel 4 sur le
galaxy s 20 f où ça va pas tarder si
c'est pas déjà là ça va pas tarder à mon
avis à lui monsieur greuet ce que tu
penses que le honor magic v sera
commercialisé en europe bientôt non je
ne pense pas samsung s 22 ultra ou
iphone 13 promax c'est plus qu'une
question de matériel c'est une question
de logiciels et j'attends de voir
réellement ce que va donner ce es22
ultra quand il sera officialisé pour
pouvoir te répondre mon bon ami rugbyman
asm force et honneur raphaël nous d'y
présenter le concept de keyzer anti
ondes de smartphones produits français
alors je connais pas mais je vais
regarder ça merci d'envoyer ça fait une
vidéo qui est un peu longue on a vu
plein plein de choses mais c'est
vachement cool j'espère que cette faq
vous aurais intérêt si on a regardé
plein de sujets puis on reparlera
développera la question comment se passe
mon métier mon business & company parce
que je pense que c'est un sujet qui
parle vraiment très intéressant j'espère
que ça vous aura intéressé on refera
peut-être une autre faq plus tard ça
vous intéresse verdict le mois en bas en
commentaire quant à moi je veux des gros
bisous à vous oui avoue avoue derrière
l'écran à toi je t'embrasse à bientôt
prenez soin de vous beaucoup de bonheur
et beaucoup d'amour et bisous
[Musique]
et